des cendres de la fumée et des ruines
c'est tout ce qu'il reste du plus grand
camp de réfugiés de grèce ce mercredi un
incendie ravageur s'est déclaré dans la
nuit et a tout emporté sur son passage
des centaines de migrants fuyant les
flammes ont dû finir leur nuit à même le
sol
une situation dramatique qui selon le
gouvernement grec a été causée par l'un
des leurs tout indique que l'incendié a
été déclenché à la suite du
mécontentement de certains réfugiés du
centre de morilles à en raison de l'
isolement nécessaire résultant de 36 cas
confirmés de kovy 19 sur 1900 tests
effectués ces derniers jours les
incendies ont été déclenchés dans des
zones autour du centre ville de
nouvelles sources d'incendié ont même
été repéré à l'intérieur selon plusieurs
ong le camp de moria était devenu une
véritable honte pour l'europe entière
et pour cause surnommé la jungle ce camp
d'une capacité totale de 2700 places
abritait plus de douze mille migrants
après la découverte d'un cas de kovy de
le camp avait été placé en confinement
total et ce jusqu'au 21 septembre une
catastrophe humanitaire qui relance donc
le débat sur l'accueil des demandeurs
d'asile en europe
je suis profondément attristé par les
événements de la nuit dernière au camp
de réfugiés de moria en grèce mon
département en a été informé ce matin
j'ai demandé au vice-président
margaritis qui menace de se rendre en
grèce dans les plus brefs délais nous
sommes prêts à apporter notre soutien
avec les états membres
notre priorité est la sécurité de ceux
qui sont laissées sans abri
une situation qui soulève l'indignation
notamment en allemagne à berlin hambourg
ou encore cologne
des rassemblements se sont tenus ce
mercredi en soutien aux réfugiés du camp
les manifestants demandent l'évacuation
de moria et la réouverture des
frontières afin d'accueillir ces
migrants reste à savoir si les membres
de l'union européenne
sauront trouver un terrain d'entente sur
ce sujet épineux